want to know what's out there as much as
you want to know what's out there
so are ufos real that is the question a
congressional committee was talking
about today good evening and thanks for
staying with us at 6 30 i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis lawmakers
haven't held a hearing like this in half
a century defense officials telling
lawmakers they have some 400 reports
from military personnel of ufos or uaps
and while they can explain some they
simply cannot explain others washington
correspondent alexander limon reports
in the first hearing of its kind in 50
years defense officials confirmed
sightings of unidentified flying objects
or as the military calls them uaps but
we have detected no emanations
within the uap task force that that is
that would suggest it's anything
non-terrestrial officials said there
have been no collisions between u.s
aircraft and the objects but there have
been 11 near misses and have we
attempted to communicate with those
objects
no
we don't even put out a
alert saying you know identify yourself
some of the objects like the triangles
in this video were later classified as
drones but defense officials said there
are sightings they still can't explain
the defense department says it is taking
reports seriously and that it continues
to expand its office that's gathering
and analyzing reports of ufos it's not
about finding alien spacecraft but about
delivering dominant intelligence some
lawmakers said the sightings could be
evidence of secret u.s or foreign
technology
but california congressman adam schiff
was unsure there was something there
measurable by multiple instruments and
yet it seems to move in directions that
are inconsistent
with what we know of physics or science
after the public hearing a classified
version of the hearing on ufos continued
behind closed doors in washington
alexandra limon